voice exercises [ __ ] my doing roll it
hey what's going on YouTube now if you
haven't heard about this one look at
this one this bunch of [ __ ] doozy now
before I go ahead and talk about this
topic I cannot make this [ __ ] up
Spokane's n-double-a-cp leader has been
outed out to be a hundred percent white
now this in and of itself doesn't sound
too shocking because yes there can be
white activists when it comes to other
people's cultures and races however she
has been telling everybody that she's
black I cannot make this [ __ ] up this is
some [ __ ] that you will see on a Dave
Chappelle's get house real
the confusion did not end there recently
on the interview she was confronted and
asked if her parents were white she
responded that's very I don't I don't
know what you're implying I don't I
don't understand the question she write
them that's where you made your rookie
mistake
but somebody asks you a simple question
that almost everybody should be able to
answer like that and you crumble that's
where you [ __ ] up Rachel what time is
this oh man come you don't know the time
this is what mr. ring has gone on so
long and so deep that was a picture of
her standing next to a black man who she
said never in my whole life have I ever
seen somebody try so hard to be a part
of a community you know at this point as
far as I'm concerned if I could just ask
the black community to just just let her
at him because she's not even trying to
imitate black culture she she trying to
be african-american because in all
honesty grown-up people did come up to
me and told me that I should stop trying
to be black which is absolutely stupid
and offensive but never once in my life
have I been asked if I was black and
said could you imagine how hard and
difficult it was for her to do this she
has an amazing work ethic have any of
you out there actually seen her original
picture this girl look like a dutch
housewife that just got done churning
butter she can we even go further back
and talk about this Facebook picture
that she posted about her nestled she
said going with the natural look you are
[ __ ] crazy you gotta admit she's
pretty [ __ ] funny how is this real
this is not real is it and I don't want
to hear about this argument about
transgenders and transracial people
apparently being the same thing that is
not the [ __ ] same that's kind of
offensive to transgender people she went
as far as to make up stories about
racial discrimination and how she got
abused at home she actually said that
her parents had a baboon whip that they
got from South Africa that they used to
beat her oh you just go to make [ __ ] up
on the spot this is [ __ ] insane
this [ __ ] started making up a story
that was very similar to Lion King
Rachel can you tell me a little bit
about your family well how could I put
this now this gets even more weird
because her parents actually did adopt
some kids from Africa and she took one
of her brothers and said that that was
her son it's amazing how far she has
gone and in all honesty she doesn't even
look like she just looks crispy white
this girl look like a perfectly cooked
Thanksgiving turkey and [ __ ] this is
absolutely amazing good you fool
everybody I could just picture you
chillin with a whole bunch of black
folks a [ __ ] like girl you know how
there might be discrimination cuz I'm
black soda kinda maybe I'm white our
dozen simple as white folks test Jesse
was true you didn't even have to ask her
if repair for white Rachel how do you
feel about rock music [ __ ] it I'm a
place of music dance to the rhythm spray
simple [ __ ] she's been outed like that
why my stomach look like a marshmallow
you know on a serious note it actually
does turn out that she is resigning you
know I feel like I say something though
aside from all the hilarity her being
the n-double-a-cp leader I do got to say
that she is making a positive impact so
one could say well who kind of cares
right but for me in this situation I
think the issue goes a lot deeper than
that I don't even know if you can really
label this as cultural appropriation too
because it goes even further than that
doesn't it and this is not a racial note
thing where you could take it however
you want her growing up as a white woman
as much as you want to be a part of that
black community or black culture you
don't know what that culture really does
go through duty for instance you can say
as much as you want you know how hard it
is to have strict Asian parents and you
know growing up here coming to the
country without any money and making
something of yourself yeah you can
emphasize that but you will never
understand and that's not a problem you
don't have to be black in order to do
positive things for the community to
better explain this it's kind of like
having your cake and eating it too it
just doesn't work out that way
you cannot benefit from being a white
female in America and say that you're
black how does that work out what you're
doing may have been positive and nobody
is really overlooking that part it's
just that the way you did it kind of
makes it hard for people to digest for
me obviously I'm not a part of the black
community even though I did grow up in a
big part of it this is just weird
I don't know it's kind of funny I'm not
mad
I'm not black I'm just laughing it is
hot I went through this sweat [ __ ]
sure now I'm just hotness this woman
charade has gone on so long and so deep
that's what she said